it looks like there's going to be a few
new kill Tony regulars for us to get
used to on top of Hans potentially being
on his way out David Lucas announced his
kill Tony retirement last night on the
live stream after his normal roast
battle with Tony this is officially his
full-time retirement party right now in
front of you guys
any people in the audience were very
surprised by this announcement obviously
but as Tony said during the show these
guys have taken off the past few years
and now with more time that they need to
focus on their own careers plus they'll
still have the option to pop in on
Mondays and perform on all the episodes
of kill Tony they want instead of having
to be there every single week